[Musik]
man muss mit dem wort sintflut
vorsichtig sein aber in anbetracht
dieser bilder
trifft es zu wie aus dem nichts kam das
wasser so viel in so kurzer zeit dass es
kein halten gab ganze häuser weggerissen
autos lkw erst recht was sich
generationen aufgebaut haben war in
minuten dahin noch lässt sich nicht
abschätzen welches ausmaß die schäden
haben aber alle die jetzt dabei sind zu
helfen und die rettung koordinieren sind
sich einig dieses hochwasser im westen
ist eine katastrophe guten abend und wir
kommen zu diesem zdf spezial sophie man
zur stunde weiß sind mehr als 40
menschen in diesem hochwasser ums leben
gekommen darunter feuerwehrleute die
helfen wollten und noch immer werden
dutzende anwohner vermisst
wir haben knapp 45 minuten zeit um zu
sortieren was da passiert ist und
beginnen in nordrhein-westfalen dort
sind zum teil mehr als 150 liter wasser
pro quadratmeter vom himmel gekommen das
ist der ausnahmezustand
altena im sauerland vor 24 stunden
eigentlich ist die länge ein kleines
flüsschen nun reist sie alles mit sich
autos fundamente und auch menschen heute
am tag danach ist der pegel etwas
gesunken dafür nun schlamm und geröll
und noch immer wasser wo früher stadt
war
die menschen die hier leben und gegen
die fluten gekämpft haben sind noch
immer erschüttert
die bilder die wir heute gesehen haben
sind unvorstellbar da wo straßen und
bürgersteige waren ist einfach nichts
mehr
die straßen wurden unterspült und am
ende weggespült autos wurden wie
spielzeuge weg bewegt wir wollten
gestern eigentlich nur eine oma den
strom im keller abschalten und sind
danach selber in eine notsituation
geraten und aus dieser hat uns unser
freund dirk ohne zu zögern und sein
leben aufs spiel gesetzt und uns mit
seinen raten lager in einer
spektakulären aktion herausgeholt ein 46
jähriger feuerwehrmann kommt hier in
altena ums leben nachdem er geholfen hat
einen anwohner aus den fluten zu retten
mindestens ein weiterer feuerwehrmann
stirbt im sauerland im einsatz
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
armin laschet ist heute mittag in
gedanken bei den opfern der
flutkatastrophe als er sich in hagen ein
bild von der lage machen kein wort was
wir sprechen kann diesen verlust
ersetzen aber dennoch sind die gedanken
bei alledem was wir jetzt hier
organisieren müssen
bei den familien derer die ums leben
gekommen ist sind wir haben noch kein
genaues lagebild über die opfer die wir
im ganzen land nordrhein westfalen zu
beklagen haben
aber auch hier können wir von mehreren
toten ausgehen die opfer dieser
flutkatastrophe geworden sind mindestens
24 menschen sind in nordrhein westfalen
ums leben gekommen 15 alleine im raum
euskirchen melden die behörden heute
nachmittag und etliche werden nach wie
vor vermisst
dort wo das wasser wieder gewichen ist
so plötzlich wie es kam versuchen die
menschen nun zu verstehen was passiert
ist wie hier in stolberg bei aachen
das ist unglaublich da kann man wirklich
nicht vorstellen die bilder kann man
nicht vergessen ich glaube da braucht
man auch viele jahre um das alles zu
verdauen
nun gilt es mit den schäden fertig zu
werden der höhepunkt der flut scheint
zumindest in stolberg überstanden wenn
man hier steht spürt man was ich gestern
hier ereignet haben muss und wie
dramatisch die situation gewesen sein
muss als innerhalb weniger minuten in
zehn minuten erzählen hier einige das
wasser kam und alles mitgerissen hat und
das leben der menschen von jetzt auf
gleich verändert hat immer wieder hängt
es hier an zu regnen
aber das wasser scheint sich
zurückzuziehen und alle hoffen dass das
schlimmste vorüber ist wie hoch die
schäden am ende sind weiß im moment noch
mit
das land verspricht den betroffenen
städten und kreisen hilfe in welcher
höhe vermag ministerpräsident laschet
noch nicht zu sagen
das kann man zur minute noch nicht
beziffern weil wir die schäden noch
nicht genau kennen
aber wir werden die kommunen die
betroffenen nicht alleine lassen sondern
als land hier auch hilfe leisten damit
nordrhein westfalen in dieser situation
solidarisch zusammen steht und wir auch
solidarisch die folgen dieser
katastrophe gemeinsam bewältigen
altena im sauerland ist nach wie vor von
der außenwelt abgeschnitten
straßen sind noch immer unpassierbar die
menschen sind mehr oder weniger auf sich
allein gestellt doch man hilft sich in
der not gegenseitig so schildert ist
heute francesco cura aus dem
eingeschlossenen katastrophen ergibt
also was hier passiert welche leute hier
zusammen halten das ist einfach
unfassbar
wir brauchen viel hilft viel geduld man
kann es nicht in worte fassen was hier
passiert ist
freunde von mir bekannte und viele
fremde haben von heute auf morgen
einfach ihr hab und gut verloren das
wasser drückt durch die wände in das
haus ein
die leute sind teilweise ohne strom in
den häusern eingesperrt ja was soll man
dazu sagen
tote verletzte vermisste wer weiß wie
viele am ende unser stunde droht die
steinbachtalsperre im kreis euskirchen
zu brechen
mehrere tausend anwohner müssen
evakuiert werden das hochwasser hat
nordrhein westfalen weiter fest im griff
alexander hettich sie es in den ganzen
tag in hagen unterwegs gewesen und
vielen häusern sieht man die schweren
schäden aber da ist ja noch mehr
passiert was auf den ersten blick gar
nicht so verheerend aus sieht natürlich
dass hier bald anschaut das was dahinter
meer rauscht ist normalerweise ein
kleiner bach und das ist normalerweise
ein baum der an diesem tag steht ja
vorne sehen seine mauer die zum größten
teil weg gespült ist dahinter war mal
ein garten und dieser garten ist
praktisch komplett verschwunden schlimm
ist das für die besitzer für die
anwohner für die besitzer der häuser wie
martin brüggemann dem dieses
wunderschöne kleine häuschen von 1876
gehört das haus steht noch aber die
fundamente sind möglicherweise
unterspült und das trifft es sehr schwer
wir haben das gestern
ja man ganz im ersten moment nicht
begreifen dass es ist eigentlich irreal
ich weiß nicht ob ich bis jetzt ganz
begriffen habe was passiert ist man ist
einfach nur unter schock es geht hier ja
man hat sich einfach über jahre hinweg
ging irgendwie eine existenz
nicht nur materielle werte sondern
einfach ja es ist das gefühl von
ohnmacht
welche konkreten ängste haben sie jetzt
das fundament man sieht ja wie die
wassermassen da quasi an den steinen
vorbeirauschen also normalerweise war ja
genau bis zur ecke des hauses eine bach
begrenzungsmauer diese mauer ist
komplett weg
und im augenblick ist das fundament
ungeschützt der strömung ausgesetzt und
wenn noch einmal so ein ereignis
passiert dann wenn wahrscheinlich diese
häuser nicht das verkraften die werden
nicht stehen bleiben können das ist ja
es ist eine angst um die ganze existenz
der ministerpräsident hat hilfen
angekündigt wie wichtig ist dass sie
hilfe bekommen von land und kommunen es
ist nicht nur wichtig dass wir hilfe
bekommen es ist auch wichtig dass diese
hilfe schnell kommt keiner weiß wie sich
eventuell das wetter auch eventuell
nochmal entwickelt und wir haben hier
viele tatkräftige leute ich habe von
ganz vielen hilfe angeboten bekommen es
gibt hier viel solidarität in der
nachbarschaft das ist auch was
besonderes ich bin dafür dankbar ich
musste nur bisher jeden sagen es gibt
nichts zu tun
ich kann selber nichts tun keiner kann
was tun man ist wie gelähmt bevor hier
nicht eine eine mauer den bach weder von
den grundstücken trend kann man mit
nichts anfangen es ist hier alles in
höchster gefahr
ganz ganz herzlichen dank ihnen alles
gute ja also hier in hagen hat es keine
toten gegeben aber die schäden in der
stadt sind extrem überall zu sehen und
auch hier geht es um existenzfrage für
diese eindrücke live aus hagen alexander
roth ich schaue mir auf dass andere
bundesland das schwer unter dieser
katastrophe leiden muss in
rheinland-pfalz trifft es vor allem den
raum trier und die eifel
allein im kreis ahrweiler sterben 18
menschen
die aa schlängelt sich durch dieses tal
und fließt dabei fast kreisrund um den
kleinen ort schuld diese lage wurde ihm
nun zum verhängnis als aus dem fluss
reißende fluten wurden zufahrt auf
schuld aus der luft die a hat sich
inzwischen wieder weitgehend in ihr
flussbett zurückgezogen
doch auf der halbinsel von schuld haben
die fluten gewütet wie fast nirgends
sonst
das war die situation gestern der fluss
sucht sich mit macht den kürzesten weg
direkt durch den ort gnadenlos reist er
alles mit was einen strom behindern will
schließlich werden häuser zu seinen
opfern und er bedroht menschenleben
die vorläufige bilanz heute in schuld
vier häuser sind komplett weggespült
zwei weitere zur hälfte und das sind nur
die markantesten schäden zwischen den
trümmern
die sich hier an jeder ecke des ortes
finden alles kaputt
halben million
schaden
er wisse auch nicht was sie machen
sollen ganz ganz schlimmer so seit 50
jahren war hier nur feuerwehr zu sein
haben wir sowas nicht hochwasser hatten
wir schon öfter aber nicht weiter geht
so weiter flussabwärts inhalten sie die
rettung der menschen heute an der ach so
aus viele werden aus der luft direkt vom
dach ihrer häuser gerettet
alle wege ringsum sind blockiert
gefährlich der hubschrauber als letzte
hoffnung der ganze ort ist im fluss wie
die menschen auf dem weg zu festem boden
sehen können
wir haben nach jetzigem kenntnisstand
entlang der aa vom bereich adenauer bis
runter zur mündung und 100 gebäude die
teil oder komplett zerstört ist diese
zahl werden wir sicher noch korrigieren
müssen leider nach oben
naja es ist mit sicherheit die größte
katastrophe im kreis ahrweiler seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg mit einer
unglaublichen kraft und wucht hat die a-
und ihre nebenbei haben im grunde
genommen hier zerstörungen angerichtet
die auch zur konsequenz hatten dass die
rettungskräfte vollkommen an ihre
grenzen kam trecker sind derzeit als
transportmittel sehr gefragt hunderte
helfer im einsatz
die katastrophe geht in rheinland pfalz
weit über den schluss ah in der eifel
hinaus am südlichen rand der eifel liegt
trier im ortsteil ehrang wo die kühe in
die mosel mündet stehen viele straßen
unter wasser
die polizei warnt vor den gefahren und
ruft dazu auf den stadtteil wegen
überflutung zu meiden
unglaublich
katastrophen gab es sowas noch nicht
mehrere hundert menschen müssen ihre
häuser und wohnungen verlassen
in großen teilen des ortes gibt es
keinen strom mehr
das wasser steht an vielen stellen die
fluten haben auch das strahlen therapie
zentrum und das daneben liegende
krankenhaus von rang erreicht hier
werden schließlich die krankenstationen
evakuiert doch nirgendwo zeigen sich die
folgen der unwetter in rheinland pfalz
heute stärker als den schlund mit seinen
700 einwohnern in einer engen schleife
der der einst malerische ort ist nun
kaum wiederzuerkennen
und genau dort in diesem besonders
betroffenen ort schuld ist unser
reporter bobby jerry yang dort gibt es
im moment kein telefon keine
verbindungen deshalb hat er seine
eindrücke aufgezeichnet und vor wenigen
minuten überspielt wer die lage in
schuld im kreis ahrweiler hat sich ein
klein wenig entspannt soweit man das
sagen kann
zumindest hat es den ganzen tag über
nicht geregnet was aber nichts an der
unglaublichen zerstörung ändert die die
wassermassen und das unwetter der
vergangenen nacht hier angerichtet haben
bei mir ist jetzt andreas heid von der
feuerwehr verbandsgemeinde adenau herr
so hat sie und ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen sind seit der nacht hier am
arbeiten was ist jetzt gerade für sie
die wichtigste aufgabe
ja wir haben jetzt hier im prinzip die
menschenrettung abgeschlossen wir haben
ja gebäude die einen schutz gefährdet
sind und müssen staatlich begutachtet
werden und letztendlich warten wir jetzt
auf das thw um zu entscheiden wie es
jetzt weitergeht mit freiräumen von
straßen usw
menschenrettung ist abgeschlossen wir
haben keine vermissten personen aktuell
mit welchen blick schauen sie jetzt auf
die nächsten stunden auf die nacht und
vielleicht auf den nächsten morgen
bisher hat es nicht geregnet wie ist die
vorhersage der vorhersage ist leider
dass es gewittern wird hier in der
region ob es konkret hier unschuld
regnet das wissen wir nicht aber auch
die zuflüsse wenn die betroffen sind
werden uns hier wahrscheinlich nochmal
zu hochwasser führen können so dass wir
jetzt mit sorge in die nacht gucken wir
angekommen sind war es nicht möglich
dass die menschen zurück in ihre häuser
oder wohnungen kommen zwischendurch hat
man gesehen dass einige dann doch dann
doch durften mit welchem ergebnis ist da
irgendetwas zu retten gewesen durften
die wieder da rein weil die leute
wollten nach ihrem hab und gut gucken
nach persönlichen wertgegenständen und
vielleicht auch aufräumen
das ging zwischenzeitlich nicht wegen
gastank der hier ausgetreten ist
letzten endes sind einige gebäude
einsturzgefährdet können nicht betreten
werden so dass viele notunterkünfte
müssten bzw in pensionen hotels hier ist
eine unheimliche solidargemeinschaft das
ist wunderbar funktioniert so dass die
leute alle versorgt sie mit dabei
wie geht es den menschen die jetzt da
unten waren und sich die häuser
angeguckt haben tatsächlich auch mit
einem ergebnis das wirklich auch
niederschmetternd ist ja das ist für uns
auch schockierend und für die bewohner
von hier auch fassungslosigkeit auch
dass die worte hier fehlen man hat auch
die eine oder andere träne hier gesehen
dass ist schon unglaublich was den
stellenwert hat dieser einsatz für sie
und ihre kolleginnen und kollegen wie
oft kommt so etwas vor im leben eines
feuerwehrmanns einer feuerwehrfrau
hatten 2016 den starkregen ereignis was
auch zu hochwasser geführt hat
allerdings nicht in diesem ausmaß
das hat im prinzip noch keiner gesehen
dass es unvorstellbar gewesen trotz der
warnung vor starkem regen aber das kam
auch so schnell
das konnte keiner kommen sind ja so viel
von uns für den moment hier aus schuld
im kreis ahrweiler
wir bleiben hier und beobachten die lage
weiter natürlich auch die wetterlage
bisherigen danke für diese eindrücke um
uns einen überblick zu verschaffen über
das was das wasser angerichtet hat dafür
hat mein kollege tadeusz parade den
hubschrauber genommen
und tatsächlich offenbart sich von dort
oben auf beklemmende weise das ganze
ausmaß die lage diese von oben anschauen
aber der erste eindruck ist schon
ziemlich dramatisch man sieht dass der
fluss
hier mit gewaltiger kraft gestern
eingegangen ist in die stadthäuser die
sich im uferbereich befinden
flächig hier
wasser
ganz super promenade unter wasser
mittlerweile ist der wasserstand wieder
deutlich gesucht so an dieser auswahl
straße sieht man auch noch mal
mit welcher kraft hier das wasser hat
dieser stelle zum beispiel die ganze
straße weg gerissen hat
interessierte sind die a1 richtung
süden komplett
staudt
peter
der stillstand
sieht man jetzt sehr guten grund der
vollsperrung auf caa1 leverkusener kreuz
a31 komplett unter wasser
ein lastwagen
in den fluten kamen nicht weiter und man
sieht wurden auch hier schon
das wasser deutlich höher noch gestanden
hatte
in den nachrichten
und es wird sicherlich noch
lange dauern bis das wieder freigegeben
wir folgen jetzt
der einrichtung
vor dem hintergrund
der rhein ist deutlich
servicekraft
knapper der hochwassermarke einfinden
tendenz deutlich steigend
sehr zufrieden
richtung steinbachtalsperre kreis
euskirchen auf
pragmatisch
gerechnet
man sieht kann ich auch ganz deutlich
hier beschädigten schon ja dann ist
und das ist wahrscheinlich
möglicherweise wirklich nicht mehr lange
halten wird
man sieht die rettungskräfte thw stehen
am rand beobachten die lage ganz genau
aber von hier oben sieht es schon sehr
sehr dramatisch aus dass es uns auch den
grund
warum die komplette a 61 hier gesperrt
worden ist weil wenn dieser damm bricht
und diese tagesstätte sich entleert dann
das wirklich für die darunter liegenden
dörfer in trier wenn ich jetzt verbunden
mit der ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland pfalz malu dreyer guten amt
sie leben in dieser stadt aber sie haben
heute noch weitere vom hochwasser
betroffene region aufgesucht wie sehr
schmerzt sie das was wir dort überall
gesehen haben ja das mag schon sehr wir
trauern dem rheinland pfalz denn diese
naturkatastrophe hat ganz ganz viel
kaputt gemacht es hat menschenleben
gekostet wir vermissen nach wie vor
menschen
es geht weiter mit den einsatzkräften
die immer noch menschen retten die auf
dächern sich gerettet haben versucht
haben zu retten
tatsächlich haben sie ja bilder eben
auch gezeigt von der grossen zerstörung
viele menschen haben angst um ihre
existenz
es ist wirklich ein schlimmer tag für
unser bundesland wir haben vorhin
menschen gehört die alles verloren haben
wenn es um hilfen geht heißt es von der
politik immer das geht schnell und
unbürokratisch tut es das wirklich
ja ich denke schon dass das unser
anspruch ist und das werden wir
natürlich auch einlösen
wir haben in unserem sonder kabinett
heute entschieden dass das land
rheinland pfalz 50 millionen euro zur
verfügung stellt für eine soforthilfe
vor allem bezogen auf die einrichtungen
die infrastruktur in den kommunen
aber wir haben ja auch heute für
zugesagt bekommen vom bund es ist eine
so große naturkatastrophe dass es nicht
möglich ist dass kommunen und land das
alleine stemmen werden insofern habe ich
mich gefreut dass olaf scholz aber auch
im namen der ganzen bundesregierung
heute auch in rheinland pfalz war und
nun zugesichert hat dass wir
unterstützung bekommen was lernen sie
aus diesem tag wird rheinland-pfalz noch
mehr in den hochwasserschutz investieren
wir sind ein bundesland in dem es häufig
hochwasser gibt und wir haben immer auch
in der vergangenheit hohe beträge
investiert in den hochwasserschutz
aber wir wissen seit einigen jahren auch
dass die starkregenereignisse die ganz
viel mit dem klimawandel zu tun haben
eine andere art des hochwassers ist was
heute passiert ist in unserem land das
ist wirklich einfach nur schrecklich so
etwas ist noch nie dagewesen aber klar
ist schon dass wir einerseits noch mehr
tempo machen werden da ist das land
rheinland pfalz eigentlich schon ganz
gut um klimaschutz zu forcieren und zum
anderen werden wir weiter unsere
kommunen unterstützen darin eben auch an
orten wo man hoch was er eigentlich gar
nicht so erwartet wirklich auch für
hochwasserschutz präventiv tätig zu sein
auch dafür stellen wir beratung und geld
zur verfügung aber gehört zur wahrheit
auch dass es einen vollständigen schutz
offenbar nicht geben kann
das ist natürlich auch ein stück
wahrheit aber was wir heute an dramatik
erleben
das ist schon etwas ganz
außerordentliches ich denke wir müssen
uns ein das heißt darauf einstellen dass
sich einfach starkregen ereignisse noch
einmal anders auswirken wie hochwasser
was wir so kennen an unseren flüssen
aber zum anderen muss es uns noch mehr
motivieren wirklich mit ganzer kraft
daran zu arbeiten den klimaschutz nach
vorne zu bringen denn wir erleben mit
diesen starkregenereignissen doch jetzt
schon seit einiger zeit und heute ganz
dramatisch was der klimawandel eben tut
und damit wollen wir nicht leben war mit
können wir nicht umgehen es ist so
traurig für unser bundeslandes wer tote
zu beklagen haben und wir werden alles
daran setzen in diesem thema eines der
bundesländer zu sein was ganz stark
voran geht
vielen dank malu dreyer ja für diese
information dankeschön
in diesem in diesen stunden haben so
viele alle hände voll zu tun aber da
sind noch jene die zeit finden mit ihrem
handy das unfassbare zu dokumentieren
die sozialen medien sind voll davon
dieses dramatische augenzeugen video aus
nordrhein westfalen verbreitet sich
gerade in sozialen medien
ein mann wird wohl in letzter sekunde
von der feuerwehr aus den fluten
gerettet
danach setzten die retter in vicht einem
stadtteil von stolberg ihre fahrt fort
wohl auf der suche nach weiteren
eingeschlossenen und menschen in not
der anwohner der alles mit seinem handy
filmt ist hörbar geschockt
nun mal
der gleiche ortsteil am nächsten morgen
es ist unfassbar dass auch du hier das
war mal ein riesen auto also was hier
los ist das ist wie im kriegsgebiet das
ist absolut auch diese aufnahmen aus
ahrweiler in rheinland pfalz stammen
nicht von professionellen fernseh
kameras sondern von entsetzten anwohnern
die hilflos mit ansehen müssen wie alles
versinkt
selbst dieser wohnwagen wird von den
wassermassen mitgerissen als wäre er aus
papier
auch im nordrhein-westfälischen schalk
mühle an der volme trauen anwohner ihren
augen kaum
das eigentlich auf social media ist die
anteilnahme groß straßen beziehungsweise
dörfer sind gar nicht mehr wieder zu
erkennen so viele leute an ihre existenz
freunde und familie betroffener anwohner
aus stolberg nutzen ihre große
reichweite auf instagram und wollen
helfen
wir haben jetzt ein spendenkonto
eröffnet werden eben mit dem
bürgermeister gesprochen
diese sind grad mit ganz anderen dingen
beschäftigt weil sie immer noch nicht
alle leute da rausholen konnten
das problem ist auch dass jetzt die
talsperre gebrochen ist das heißt es
wird noch mal mehr wasser nachkommen
die hilfsbereitschaft und das mitgefühl
sind groß doch angesichts dieser
augenzeugen aufnahmen braucht es wohl
viel mehr
bis hier alles wieder beim alten ist mag
zugeschaltet ist jetzt professor jörn
birkmann spezialist für raum- und
umweltplanung von der uni stuttgart sie
verpassen auch berichte für den
weltklimarat schulamt gegen regen in
diesen mengen spüren wir machtlosigkeit
aber was sind denn mögliche faktoren um
diese enormen schäden zu verringern gibt
es überhaupt einen denkbaren schutz
also seien weiter schon deutlich
geworden dass natürlich solche
extremereignisse nicht vollständig
irgendwie beherrscht werden können das
wird ja auch deutlich gerade wenn man
das thema starkregen sieht was eben
nicht nur an flüssen auftritt sondern
die eher die kleinen orte auch zeigen
mitten in ja weiter weg gelegenen
bereichen von flüssen trotzdem kann man
natürlich jetzt die frage stellen wenn
es schnelle hilfe gibt wo müsste man
investieren um schäden zu vermeiden und
da würde ich schon empfehlen dass man
natürlich prüft kann man bestimmte
straßen für die ableitung dieser
starkregenereignisse besser vorbereiten
kann man auch schutz vor diesen
geröllmassen stärker schaffen dass
wissen wir zumindest aus vergangenen
ereignissen dass man da auch sicherlich
jetzt die chance das fenster nutzen
sollte diesen wiederaufbau mit
klimaanpassung schutz vor solchen
schäden im grunde zu verbinden ohne
strom und handynetz ist es nahezu
unmöglich schnell
hilfe zu koordinieren was muss man aus
diesen fällen lernen das ist ein gutes
beispiel das natürlich gerade kritische
infrastrukturen ob das krankenhäuser
oder kommunikationseinrichtungen sind
oder stromnetz sicher besonders
geschützt werden müssen und das wissen
wir auch aus dem elbe hochwasser also
hier wäre es wirklich an gesagt dass man
natürlich mit zum beispiel starkregen
gefahrenkarten prüft was kann passieren
was heißt das und natürlich ist
besonders bedauerlich wenn man das
gerade brauchen handy zur warnung wenn
dann plötzlich die netze ausfallen ist
das natürlich schon auch in sich eine
eigene katastrophe die man eigentlich
vorher vor dem ereignis angehen kann
auch wenn die meteorologen jetzt
entwarnung geben sich die die chance was
zu ändern ist jetzt nach dem ereignis
viel größer bzw muss man wirklich
anpacken auch vor dem hintergrund 40
toten was heißt das für dich gemeinden
aber auch für jeden einzelnen der
irgendwo ein haus besitzt oder kaufen
will
ich denke es wäre schon günstig wenn man
eben vor drei jahren ministry sind hat
das angesprochene herr laschet ja auch
jetzt strategisch auch sagt was kann man
leuten an die hand geben damit sie sich
besser schützen können es war voll von
dem fundament die rede
wenn also leute zum beispiel bauanträge
stellen wäre es schon wichtig dass man
dort informationen zum beispiel zu
starkregen gefahren mit auf den weg gibt
auch in köln in mainz oder in stuttgart
zahlen sie für ein haus heute enorme
summen das heißt wenn man das am anfang
mit bedenkt oder beim umbau ist man hier
besser vorbereitet noch bei städten
werden sie in stuttgart ja auch ist man
gut beraten wenn man hier solche
gefahrenkarten auch wirklich nutzt um
baufirmen um bestimmte vorhaben auch
bestimmten krisen sich darauf
vorzubereiten das heißt also auch
strategisch in die planung einzubeziehen
danke professor bergmann riegert
wetterkatastrophen machen nicht halt vor
landesgrenzen es ist eine gemeinsame
herausforderung schauen wir auf das
wasser rund um deutschland passiert die
schweiz belgien luxemburg die
niederlande auch hier enorme schäden
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen kündigte heute an brüssel wird
helfen die gemeinde total nötig die
einwohner haben keinen strom keine
handyverbindung auch das militär ist im
einsatz doch die retter bleiben oft
selbst stecken die strömung ist zu stark
in der not viel solidarität
das wasser ist die ganze zeit gestiegen
sie haben mich geholt ich bin 84 jahren
manchmal kommen die soldaten auch durch
die menschen haben in ihren häusern
ausgeharrt bislang gibt es in der region
sechs tote viele werden vermisst ein
überblick ist schwer
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass
es jemals so schlimm war wir tun alles
um die situation in den griff zu
bekommen
im moment haben die wassermassen die
kontrolle die stadt lüttich besonders
betroffen die autobahn gesperrt der
zugverkehr in der provinz eingestellt in
der stadt steht das wasser bis zur
zweiten etage der fußmarsch steigt
weiter
die behörden haben die menschen
aufgefordert sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
die stadt liegt unterhalb eines
sperrwerks das was aus den bergen
sammelt sich in der masse und hier kurz
hinter lüttich wird es zum problem denn
dieses spätwerk das wird gerade
renoviert und nicht alle tore können
geöffnet werden und so staut sich das
wasser dahinter und der bürgermeister
der stadt lüttich der wahn tiefer
gelegene stadtteile könnten noch heute
überschwemmt werden alexandra wüst muss
irgendwie das wasser aus ihrem
restaurant kriegen stadt gäste zu
bewirten
das lokal liegt direkt am fluss mitten
im vom hochwasser geplagten luzern dass
das wasser kommen wird war schon in der
nacht klar
wir haben gestern schon sehr viele
vorbereitungen gemacht auch vorgestern
haben aber jetzt heute in der nacht etwa
um 45 uhr hat dann richtig angefangen
reihen zu drücken von allen seiten
und da wussten wir so jetzt müssen wir
noch mal eine schippe drauflegen haben
wir jetzt verschiedene tauchpumpen
organisiert wie groß der
hochwasserschaden am ende tatsächlich
ist will und kann alexander wüst noch
nicht absehen
die schweizer befürchten dass die pegel
noch höher steigen als beim
jahrhunderthochwasser 2005 seitdem haben
sie im ganzen land massiv in
hochwasserschutz maßnahmen investiert
sie können durchatmen nach der
vergangenen nacht hier in luzern doch es
herrscht immer noch gefahrenstufe 5 und
es besteht immer noch die gefahr dass
sie diese brücke eine hauptverkehrsader
sperren müssen wenn das wasser weiter
steigt
die lage bleibt vor allem rund um die
schweizer seen angespannt auch wenn es
bisher weniger geregnet hat als am
vortag prognostiziert
und wenn wir den heutigen tag dann
überstanden haben dann haben wir langsam
dann gegen ende woche anfangs nächster
woche ja schöner das wetter in aussicht
und dann sollte sich die situation
langsam wieder entspannen wenn es aber
wieder anfängt zu regnen drohen noch
mehr überschwemmungen erdrutsche und nur
gänge vielerorts in der schweiz
katja horn chance unserer
wetterredaktion wir haben vorhin die
menschen aus den betroffenen regionen
gehört so viel regen haben sie noch nie
erlebt deckt sich das mit dem was ihre
daten hergeben
das deckt sich mit unseren daten in
vielen regionen rund um köln und auch in
der eifel wurden ganz verbreitet tages
rekorde eingestellt also noch niemals
seit beginn der messung gab es so viel
regen wie jetzt in den vergangenen 24
stunden mal ein beispiel in köln
stammheim sind 153 5 liter regen pro
quadratmeter gefallen
in köln stammheim wird seit 1945
gemessen und der letzte rekord der kam
aus dem jahr 2017 das waren 95 liter
daran sieht man wie exorbitant viel
regen darunter gekommen ist und solche
tages rekorde gab es eben ganz
verbreitet
um mal die größenordnung besser zu
verstehen was unterscheidet diese
wetterlage von schlechten sommer die es
ja immer mal gab also das was wir
landläufig unter schlechtem sommer
verstehen ist eigentlich typischer
mitteleuropäischer sommer da zieht dann
ein tief nach dem anderen über uns
hinweg jetzt aber hatten wir ein tief
das tief bernd das genau sich über
deutschland festgesetzt hat über den
alpen und das hat eben über tage immer
wieder sehr warme luft aus richtung
mittelmeer sehr feuchte luft aus
richtung mittelmeer und die kühlere luft
vom nordatlantik zusammengemischt und
dann gab es diese exklusive mischung ist
gab ja auch kräftige gewitter
aber das verheerendste war sicherlich
der dauerregen jetzt in den vergangenen
anderthalb tagen im westen deutschlands
danke für diese information vom zdf da
katja hornuf zunächst war es ein gefühl
irgendwie wird das meer mit den wettern
den hitzeperioden den schäden aber die
bilanz der deutschen versicherer zeigt
es ist mehr als das es ist erwiesen und
wir bekommen es auch zu spüren auch
finanziell
wir sprechen gleich mit unseren
zdf.umwelt experten über diese klima
auswirkungen zunächst aber ein blick auf
das was mehr und mehr geschickt juli
1997 nach heftigen regenfällen
verursachten hochwasser der oder in
brandenburg große schäden
45.000 helfer bemühen sich bei einem der
größten katastropheneinsätze die
aufgeweichten dämme mit sandsäcken zu
sichern
august 2002 extreme regenfälle lassen
die elbe und ihre nebenflüsse heftig
anschwellen in dresden erreicht das
hochwasser einen rekordstand mindestens
20 menschen sterben allein in sachsen
in bayern werden durch eine flutwelle
der donau große teile von regensburg und
passau überschwemmt
vier jahre später sind wieder sachsen
und andere ostdeutsche bundesländer
betroffen
in norddeutschland erreichen die fluten
der elbe neue höchststände
und im august 2010 wieder hochwasser
besonders in sachsen extreme regenfälle
führen zu heftigen überschwemmungen
mindestens zehn menschen ertrinken in
den fluten
juni 2013 überflutungen in ganz
mitteleuropa in deutschland und den
nachbarländern sterben 25 menschen der
gesamtschaden liegt bei zwölf milliarden
euro
auch punktuell führen starkregen zu
katastrophen im frühsommer 2016 rausch
nach einem starkregen einem meter hohe
flutwelle durch simbach am inn
dieser ort ist am stärksten betroffen in
ganz niederbayern kommen durch die
fluten sieben menschen ums leben
kurz zuvor sind regionen in baden
württemberg zentrum eines sturmtiefs der
ort braunsbach wird durch geröll und
schlammmassen verwüstet im juli 2017
wieder eine unwetter- katastrophe in
norddeutschland tief alfred bietet vor
allem in niedersachsen braune fluten
strömen durch die straßen von goslar
auch andere städte stehen teils unter
wasser volker angres leiter der zdf
umwelt redaktion kann man überhaupt von
dieser entwicklung noch die augen
verschließen das fällt ja natürlich
absolut schwer vor allen dingen vor dem
hintergrund dass ja genau diese
ereignisse vor mehr als 20 jahren von
den klimaforschern ja schon vorher
gesagt worden sind sie haben einfach
ihre wettermodelle angeguckt ihre
klimamodelle und sind zu dem ergebnis
gekommen eine auswirkung der
klimaveränderung werden eben diese stark
wetterereignisse extremwetterereignisse
sein und das gibt auch daten dafür zum
beispiel die arktis ändert sich die wird
dreimal schneller wärme als der rest der
welt und dies ist ein wesentlicher
faktor im weltweiten klimageschehen
genau wie die tropischen regenwälder im
amazonasgebiet wenn dort die
abholzungsrate weiter geht werden sich
diese die wälder von selber abschaffen
weil sie nicht mehr genug feuchtigkeit
haben um zu überleben auch das wird man
hier dann spüren also wir haben dieses
chaotische wetter verhalten dass es in
anführungsstrichen normal plus aber
jetzt die veränderten randbedingungen
und die schaffen diese extreme
wir reden darüber gerade gestern wurden
die pläne in brüssel vorgestellt bis
2030 den co2 ausstoß um 55 prozent zu
senken
das ist noch nicht beschlossen da wird
erst mal noch verhandelt wird das
reichen
nein das wird natürlich so nicht reichen
und vor allen dingen kann man ja absehen
dass diverse lobbyisten dann
verschiedene mitgliedsstaaten doch
andere ideen haben weil es denen einfach
zu anstrengend ist zu teuer ist die
wirtschaft nicht mitkommt ist es
eigentlich so gedacht dass die eu als
staatenverbund ein zeichen setzen möchte
dass man einfach sagt wir kriegen das
irgendwie hin wir müssen das hinkriegen
weil ja auch viele industrieländer dabei
sind und die müssen die umstellung dann
auch schaffen die uhr alleine steht für
rund acht prozent der weltweiten
treibhausgase das reicht natürlich
hinten und vorne nicht also muss man
gucken wie werden die maßnahmen die in
der eu jetzt entwickelt werden
exportfähig wie kann man zum beispiel
regenerative energien stärker in länder
in kontinente wie afrika bringen wie
kriegt man dort die infrastruktur hin
wir üben die auch gerade noch ziemlich
bei dem thema e mobilität da frage ich
mich auch wie sollen die millionen
elektroautos eigentlich fahren wenn es
hinten und vorne die ladestationen ich
gewinne ist in den stromnetzen die
infrastrukturen ich gibt das sind die
großen herausforderung wir müssen
versuchen das was jetzt in europa
passiert in die ganze welt zu
transportieren entsprechen gleich weiter
und schauen auf einen der gründe die das
problem mit diesem starkregen noch
verschärfen die flächenversiegelung zu
viel beton zu wenig erde
[Musik]
extremwetter in deutschland doch die
zerstörerischen wassermassen
sie sind nur der auslöser der
katastrophe die eigentliche ursache
liegt anderswo
seit jahrzehnten bereitet die
flächenversiegelung dem hochwasser den
weg in deutschland werden täglich circa
56 hektar als siedlungs und
verkehrsflächen neu ausgewiesen um kein
bauland zu verschenken lassen gemeinden
die uferbereiche einfach zubetonieren
asphalt und beton können aber kein
wasser aufnehmen
so holt sich das wasser bei starkregen
den platz zurück den der mensch im einst
genommen hat ein weiteres problem mehr
als 90 prozent der deutschen flüsse und
bäche sind über weite strecken begradigt
eingeengt und verlaufen in rohren
sobald das wasser in ein unnatürliches
flussbett gezwängt wird fließt es
schneller
flussbegradigungen werden vor allem
durchgeführt um flächen für die
landwirtschaft zu gewinnen aber auch um
ein gewässer für die schifffahrt zu
nutzen
schließlich leitet auch die zerstörung
der auenlandschaft den überschwemmungen
vorschub rund 80 prozent der natürliche
überflutungsflächen gingen bisher in
deutschland verloren natürliche
überflutungsflächen auch retentionsräume
genannt sind ein wichtiger schutz vor
extremen hochwasser wie ein schwamm
speichern sie das nass zubetoniert
begradigt verbaut die fehlentwicklungen
der letzten jahre haben dazu geführt
dass die bäche und flüsse ihre bedeutung
für die umwelt verloren haben und so
fordern experten eindringlich ein neues
wassermanagement volker angres gerade
die metropolen verpassen sich gerade
eine enorme verdichtung es wird enger
und höher gebaut sehenden auges in die
nächste katastrophe kann man so sagen
ist ja im grunde ganz klar wenn ich
immer mehr menschen auf einem fleck habe
in diesen metropolen dann steigen
natürlich auch die risiken wenn solche
starkregen ereignisse aber auch stark
wie
der ereignisse wir haben ja auch
tornados mittlerweile in deutschland
wenn die dann passieren dann weiß ich
nicht wie dann die hilfskräfte noch
evakuieren wollen das wird echt
schwierig also die strategie müsste
tatsächlich sein
zugucken wie kann ich im ländlichen raum
in der fläche noch die siedlungen
reaktivieren wir haben wir gerade in
ostdeutschland viele gebiete verfallen
die dörfer der verfallende häuser
das wäre vielleicht auch ein ansatz
darüber nachzudenken und in der tat was
eben im beitrag auch rauskam seit jahren
reden wir darüber die
flächenversiegelung runterzufahren zu
stoppen was ist was passiert aber
wirklichkeit immer mehr einkaufszentren
auf der grünen wiese immer mehr
autobahnen werden gebaut alles
flächenversiegelung projekte
das kann sich nicht miteinander
vertragen angenommen der klimaschutz
kommt trotz aller widrigkeiten weltweit
in gang
kann das noch hoffnung auf besserung na
ja hoffen auf besserung insofern dass
man vielleicht die chance hat das was
wir als klimawandel erderwärmung hier
wahrnehmen
doch auf einem gewissen niveau zu
stabilisieren die klimaforscher sagen
dieses system ist so fragil so
zerbrechlich dass es 50 60 vielleicht
sogar 70 jahre braucht um sich wieder
auszutarieren auszubalancieren und dann
weiß man nicht ob es dann auf dem niveau
stehen bleibt also auf dem heissen auf
dem erwähnten niveau oder ob es sich
auch wieder brück entwickeln kann
also man muss tatsächlich damit rechnen
auch wenn der klimaschutz perfekt laufen
sollte dass wir noch jahrzehnte lang mit
solchen ereignissen wie wir sie hier
gesehen haben möglicherweise so gern
auch sogar noch mit stärkeren
extremwetter ereignissen zu tun haben
werden also das geht weiter
und daran muss man sich auch in
irgendeiner form gewöhnen danke für
diese information volker angriff ja das
war unser zdf spezial an einem tag der
in erinnerung bleiben wird denn diese
katastrophe im westen können sich
jederzeit auch woanders wiederholen wir
haben beispiele gesehen
wir sagen vielen dank für ihr interesse
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]